our next speaker um is a longtime member
of the art community
and i will say that his stan workshop
was actually played a large role in how
i met my wife
so i want to thank you very much for
that for uh doing this and actually
he has been very helpful with my wife's
research ever since then but
my wife actually emailed me one day
asking to attend the workshop and that's
one of the first part of the story of
how we met so
thank you for the stan workshops on
multiple levels welcome
jonah gabriel hi everyone i am
jonah uh i one of the stand developers
like jared mentioned i work at columbia
university
uh i work closely with andrew gilman who
you heard from yesterday
um he's probably my closest collaborator
and i'm going to talk today about a new
way
of interfacing with stan from
r all right just a little bit of
background
first for anybody who isn't super
familiar with stan
stan is a probabilistic programming
language that allows you to fit rich
complicated bayesian models we have
interfaces for r
python julia pretty much anywhere people
are computing things
used throughout academia i think at this
point i've seen at least one stand model
in like every
every academic field where statistical
modeling is used that's probably a
slight exaggeration
but uh but it's it's all over the place
government agencies i've done trainings
in the u.s and other countries around
the world for different
government agencies most companies
a lot of not maybe the most a lot of
companies that you've heard of are using
stan
but they don't really like to talk about
it for some reason
probably maybe because they want to keep
their secrets or something but it means
we can't advertise that a lot of like
these big companies are using stamps so
that's a little bit unfortunate but i'm
very glad that they're
that they're using it um and so
we have a bunch of functionality in r so
here's a little map of the stan
ecosystem in r in the top right you kind
of have the stand
c plus code where i put the scan logo
and to get into r we have this package
called stan headers which brings all the
header files in and then the rstan
interface
branching off of our stand we have some
packages
that fit stand models for you without
you having to write your own scan code
rstan arm brms
and then we have some downstream modules
for visualizing results
doing leave one out cross validation for
in the bayesian context
doing some variable selection in the
bayesian context and we provide this
package our stand
tools which helps other people develop
our packages
for fitting stand models so there's
about i don't know somewhere between 50
and 100
packages on crayon now that have their
own
stand programs in them you know for
different applications
which is really cool some of you
probably heard of the rethinking package
but there's a whole lot of other ones
out there
and then there are some projects like
tidy bays which uh
from matthew k which isn't really part
of the stand development team but
integrates really well with all of our
tools and
r um and so this is all great our
stand's been around for a long time now
so what's the problem well unfortunately
for one this is what our forum often
looks like
we have long posts trying to help people
avoid
problems that they get when installing
stan
so for example you can see all of this
horrible looking
are these horrible looking error
messages that windows users have been
dealing with recently
previously we had issues on mac now it's
windows um
the way that rstan works is it
interfaces uh with the stan c plus plus
code through rcpp
and i love rcpp it's great but it does
uh it is a challenging way especially
with how complicated the stand c plus
libraries are to interface um
and so often what happens is something
that looks like this
uh now it doesn't have the stan logo on
there when you see this message in our
studio but it might as well
um because very often people are running
like a huge stand model and then
something happens and after hours or
something they get this message and
that's a real
real bummer so uh
well let me reset my uh my timer here
um and uh
so we're looking for ways to uh to avoid
these problems here's another problem
that we have this is the crayon
page for rstan it says the version is
2.21.2
if you look at the stand users guide it
says the version is 2.24 and i'll tell
you there's a lot of cool features that
have come out in between version 2.21
and 2.24
but it takes a long time for rstan to
make it onto crayon
in for each release there's often new
stuff that's added in the stan c plus
plus code that presents certain
challenges for interfacing with it or
cran gets
upset about something and so the r stand
package really lags behind
and you can't take advantage of some new
features like
enhanced functionality for
parallelization
of big matrix computations all sorts of
other cool stuff that's come out of
newer releases of stan
that is inaccessible on our stand for
months at a time
so we wanted to come up with a way to
solve
all of these problems this problem this
problem
this problems and our solution
[Music]
is a package that we call command stan r
um i put a little note down here on the
bottom for python users who happen to be
at the wrong conference we also have
command stand
pi so you can go look that up
and what command stan r is is
instead of interfacing with
the stan c plus plus libraries through
rcpp
we decided to instead well not instead
we still have rstam uh
but to also offer a version where
we provide an r package that actually
calls the stand
command line interface right and we'll
see what some of the advantages of that
are
of that is in a second uh before i show
that let's just see what some people are
saying since we released
this so uh stuart russell on twitter
says
exactly the same two hour model
switching from our stand to command stan
r with no changes and compile flies or
anything runs 23
faster he doesn't have any idea why
uh i don't know why either because i
don't know exactly what his model is but
my hunch is is that he's using some of
the stand functionality that's improved
between these two releases
and the fact that we can get uh the
latest stand features with command stan
r but not in our stand lets him run a
much faster model
um there's also command center is
probably also just faster than our stand
in general uh does io a little bit
better uh
handles memory better um uh
we have a lot of japanese users so i
really enjoy
reading our stan our stan tweets in
japanese but i
provide the translation for you here so
he had an error
with r stan after upgrading to r uh 4.0
i can't tell you how many
people had this problem on our forums
and how much time we've spent trying to
help everybody out
in this regard um and so
uh he switched to command stan r and
it works fine um lia sang on twitter
said i tried the toy example so i guess
it's just a toy example but it works so
well on his laptop and also on the
computing cluster that he's considering
rewriting all of his stuff in commands
10r
i assume compared to r stand before so
why is it why are people enjoying it so
much why are we excited about this
um oops i'm going to go back and i'm
going to actually jump over and show you
a little bit about
what this actually looks like so
the package is not on cran yet but you
can install it
from github using devtools or from
our repository on the stand website
using install packages
and so why is this so nice well
first of all you can install the command
stand r package
and we provide a function to install
command stand
for you um and
what that does is it allows us to
provide a function that does the
installation in a way that we think will
work most
consistently whereas often what happens
when people install our stand is they
have all sorts of weird
i don't know make flags on different
files on their computer and those causes
problems but through this install
function here we're able to
kind of help the installation work
better
it also allows you to install any
version of stan you want basically so
there's
argument here to provide the url to
whatever release you want to install so
it could install an old release the
newest release a release candidate
and the way that that it works for
anybody used to our stand this will seem
a little bit different
because we're actually using r6 classes
here
and what that lets us do is
uh have the r command stand r and
command stand pi
actually provide an almost identical
user experience right
the only difference here will be like
swapping the dollar sign for the
dot in python right and so what happens
is it takes the path to your stand
program so you write
some complicated model in stan
pass it to this function command stand
model which will compile it for you in
this case
on my system the executable is already
up to date so it'll just tell you
and it creates this r6 object which just
has this compiled
executive ball and
uh and so you can print the stand
program
but then even though you're calling the
command line interface it doesn't mean
you have to use
know how to use the command line
interface to stand you just put your
data in a list like in r
and then call our sample method right
and you can tell it how many chains you
want to run
how many chains you want to run in
parallel and then what we do is we use
the process
x package to send off uh
different processes right and run
command stand
on each of those processes bring the
results back together
and then read the results back into r
and then we provide some nice
tidy summaries of the output with the
summary function
you can use uh some of this like lambda
functionality stuff to compute functions
of your parameters like here
i estimated a model with the parameter
theta i could use this syntax to ask
what's the probability it's less than a
half
these are just nice little ways that we
integrate with like some of the tidy
groups stuff
but the real benefit of this is that
you're not going to get the types of
crashes you get running rstan in our
studio
um it's going to handle the memory a lot
better it integrates with all of our
other packages so for example it
integrates nicely with
bayes plot package which makes ggplot
objects
for showing your mcmc output um
and we've got a lot of uh tutorials
here's another one here about how it
works a little bit
internally and how we try to handle
reading the results back into r in a
more memory efficient way we use
vroom the room package so which has been
really great
um checking my time here
but in general people have been really
enjoying this new interface we will
hopefully get it onto cran
at at some point so
uh let me show you one other cool thing
that we're starting to get nice
contributors
uh for nice contributions probably also
from nice contributors although i don't
know them personally uh
so we just had a contributor mikhail
popov who contributed a new r markdown
command sound engine or i guess it's a
knitter commands fan engine
so we've had the stan engine in there
for a while which uses our stand
but that would cause a problem if you
wanted to instead use command stand
r in your knitter document or your
vignette or something but we put a fund
we have a new function
in command called register knitter
engine and what that does
is if you have a stand chunk in your
knitter
document or our markdown document it
tells
tells it to evaluate it using command
span r instead of r stand
um this is really cool the only problem
that we've had and maybe somebody
maybe there's an expert here at this
conference who could uh give me a hint
here
is that in interactive mode so this is a
rendered like our markdown document but
if i was running this in interactive
mode and just
evaluating chunks it doesn't seem to
respect
overriding the rstan engine so that's
something we need to figure out but if
you're knitting a document
it does a great job and you can now
substitute this
in for your r stand document
and so we're pretty excited about this
interface
it's not going to replace rstan
because our stan is really needed
for all of the r packages on cran
that have pre-compiled stand programs in
them
so here's the rx10 cran page and there's
a whole lot of packages down here
depending on our stand
and most of them because they depend on
our stand are able to offer
stan code that just runs out of the box
it doesn't you don't need to wait for it
to compile
so this is like the rstan arm package
and unfortunately in order to offer that
same functionality with command stand r
we basically need to get
cran to have an installed command stand
the command line interface to stand and
pre-compile everything and i don't know
if we'll be able to get them to do that
so our stand isn't going anywhere we're
going to need it as the back end for all
these packages
that want to just offer pre-compiled
stand programs
but if you're not offering pre-compiled
programs like for example the brms
package
it already offers now command stan r as
the back
end so the brms package which is one of
the more popular r packages for fitting
stam models
you can now just tell it to run your
model and command stand r
instead of r stand and the advantages to
that will be that you could get some of
the additional speed or if you have a
lot of data or parameters the command
standard package will handle memory
uh better than rstan will and
so i'm not trying to hate on rstan i'm
one of the authors of our stand but i
can't tell you how frustrating an
experienced it is when we release a new
version and then everybody has
installation troubles and we feel
terrible about it and it's
uh it's really unpleasant so we're
pretty excited about this
uh command stan r package and i just
want to show you
um but i wasn't kidding there's a python
version called command stand
pi uh and what's great about this is
that the interfaces are basically
identical with the exception of like the
dot
symbol and the dollar sign symbol
so if you're working with a colleague
and one of you wants r one of you wants
python
there's my timer with a few minute
notice
and one of you wants python you can
basically read each other's code
no problem the stand programs are always
the same they don't care what language
you're using to interface but now even
the code that you're using
in the interface so your r script will
look a lot like their python script
also helps the development so like i
work on command stand r with my
colleague
who has an amazing name rock cheshnovar
from slovenia
but mitzi and re who are working on
command standpie
we can make a lot of the design
decisions together because the
interfaces are really designed very
similarly and have the same basically
user facing experience
and i think i have two minutes left so
i'm going to basically
wrap it up here and
say that you can get in touch i don't
have a personal twitter account
um i'm trying to resist for as long as
possible
but i do tweet from the mcmc stan
account so to some of my collaborators
so you can definitely get in touch with
us from the span account
you can check out uh projects that i
work on which is basically all of the r
packages related to the spam
ecosystem reach out by email and
on the stand forums i am at jonah
and uh yeah again hopefully uh i'll do
another stan class with jared
next year uh or even later this year i
don't know now that we're all online i
guess
we can just kind of do it whenever we
want and uh thank you
very much thank you jonah
it's always great when we could have a
stand talk at the conference we always
try to
at least get one of them or going going
and if anyone is interested in a
workshop
uh about stan or otherwise send us a
message send a message to
myself tomata to joe or lauren on my
team anyone on my team
let us know what workshops you want to
see